[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Wow.
That was fun, wasn't it?
Good afternoon.
Hello.
Hello, everyone.
All right.
I am Purnima
Kochikar, and my team
has the privilege of
working with apps and games
developers globally.
The animation you just saw is
inspired by the amazing content
you create which gives people
superpowers and helps us move
the mobile ecosystem forward.
Thank you.
Before we jump into
what's new on Google Play,
let's take a moment to look
back at the amazing growth we
have seen since we
met at I/O a year ago.
You heard at the keynote
that Android and Play are
being used by increasing number
of users around the world,
and it is now active on two
billion devices monthly.
And an astounding
82 billion apps
have been installed from Google
Play in the last 12 months.
This is translating into more
developers finding success
on Google Play.
In the last year
alone, the number
of developers with more than one
million installs grew by 35%.
This is phenomenal and
makes me truly happy.
Give yourselves a very big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
We are also investing
to enable everyone
to pay for your apps and
games using forms of payment
that they prefer.
For example, Americans
prefer credit cards,
Japanese prefer DCB, and
Germans prefer PayPal,
and Brazilians prefer some kind
of a prepaid method like gift
cards which gives them
control over their payments.
The sheer scale of our payment
platform that you see behind me
continues to amaze me.
As a result, we are seeing
that increased number
of people paying for your apps
and games than ever before.
In the last year alone, the
number of new buyers on Play
grew by 30%.
In particular, we are
seeing great traction
for the subscription
business model.
The number of subscribers
grew by 2x plus
year, with 62% of the
subscribers telling us
that they use their app
at least once a day.
Beyond payments, we're also
investing in capabilities
to help you reach more
users in more ways.
The Play Store is now
available on Daydream VR
and on Chromebooks that
allows you to reach users
in interesting new ways.
Last year at I/O, we previewed
Android Instant Apps.
This allows your users to
get access to your apps
without the hurdle of
having to install the app.
We are very grateful
to many of you--
I can see you in
the audience here--
who worked with us to make
that vision a reality.
And today, we open up Android
Instant Apps to everyone.
I hope you'll all
start working on them.
And yesterday, we
previewed Android Go,
which is our optimized version
of Android for emerging markets
devices.
As you know, there
are billions of people
in emerging markets
who are coming
onto mobile for the first time.
Please take the time
to look at the Building
for Billions guidelines to help
you build for these devices.
Above all, we are taking
into account quality
in every decision we are
making on the Play Store.
Through programs
like Early Access,
we are bringing you dedicated
and highly-motivated
23 million-plus people who
are willing to test your apps
and give you feedback
while they're still
in development before you
put it up for production.
We are engaging with
indies around the world
to find the best quality games,
and we're showcasing them
on the Indie Corner.
And we are also taking
into account engagement
in all our algorithms
that shape our top charts.
And today, this evening, we will
host the second annual Google
Play Awards.
We will be celebrating
the best of the best,
acknowledging great
quality in apps and games.
I hope to see you there.
Please come.
Be inspired.
And come to celebrate what
makes great apps and games.
So, just as your apps are
giving people superpowers,
our engineering
and product teams
are working on capabilities
to give you the superpowers
to succeed on Google Play.
So are you ready to see
what they've been cooking?
You can do better than that.
All right.
Put your hands together for
Matt Henderson, group product
manager.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HENDERSON: Thanks, Purnima.
Hi, everybody.
So in your organizations,
who else besides you
cares about the
success of your app?
Who else contributes to
the success of your app?
A lot of people, right?
In a variety of roles?
Well, have a think about who
else in your organization
should be using
the Play Console.
When we started the
Console five years ago,
it was a means to get an app
from a to b, from developer
to the phone.
But over the years, it's
become much more than that.
With a variety of users
and a variety of features,
the Play Console is
playing a much broader role
in the success of your app.
With more features,
the user base
has broadened to different
roles and new organizations.
Our users now are
product managers.
They're marketing managers.
They're test engineers.
And of course, they're
Android developers.
So think about who else
in your organization
should be using
the Play Console.
Now with that growth in
the variety of features,
UI design needs to
keep things organized.
So in addition to talking
about features today,
I wanted to touch on the UI
look and feel of the Console.
You may have noticed
some changes.
We've launched a new
cleaner and clearer material
design-based Play Console.
And it has a new name.
The Play Developer Console
is now just the Play Console.
This reflects the fact
that, although all
of your organizations
develop apps, not all of you
are developers.
The user base is getting
more and more diverse
as we're playing a
more diverse role
in the success of your app.
And early feedback
about the UI suggests
we're on the right track, such
as this from the e-commerce app
Zalando.
The redesigned Play
Console is more intuitive.
It's more structured.
It's more convenient.
But of course, in
addition to a new design,
we've been hard at work
with new functionality.
So here are some highlights
of launches from the past 12
months.
There's been features to help
app quality, like beta testing
and the pre-launch report.
There's new tools to
manage the release process.
There's also new reporting
and pricing features
to help you identify and take
advantage of opportunities
to grow your business.
And now, at this
I/O, we're announcing
important new and
updated features
in all of these areas that go
even further at helping you
create high-quality
app experiences, that
go even further helping you
mitigate risk in the release
process, and they
go even further
in helping you to
achieve business success.
Now I'm going to hand over
to some more of the team
to give you a snapshot of each
of these different features,
starting with Fergus,
product manager from the Play
team in London.
[APPLAUSE]
FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks, Matt.
Who here wants to
know the secret
to get a five star
app on Google Play?
OK.
Great, I came to the right talk.
We did machine learning over
all the Google Play reviews,
and what we found is that 50%
of all the one star reviews
are talking about
stability issues.
So if you want to
increase your star rating
and reduce the number one
star ratings for your app,
the number one
thing you can do is
focus on stability
of your application.
Then once you fix
those stability issues,
what do you do to be able
to increase your star rating
to that golden five stars?
Well, you focus on design,
usability, and speed.
Yesterday in the keynote, you
might have seen Android vitals.
This is our initiative
at Google to help
you to understand the
performance and stability
of your applications.
We've had hundreds of
millions of users who've
opted in to share their
device diagnostics and usage
data with Google so that we
can be able to help partners
like you be able to
provide better experiences.
We're now giving you that
data in an aggregate fashion
so you can be able to
understand your performance.
We're starting with
three performance areas--
stability, battery,
and rendering.
We're going to be
expanding to many more
over the course
of the next year,
and so stay tuned for those.
Now, as we expand more and
more performance areas,
there's a lot of data to
be able to understand.
How do we simplify it for you?
Well, we're introducing this
concept of bad behaviors.
Bad behaviors are when your
app falls in the lowest
25% of apps for that metric.
And if you are in
the lowest 25%,
we'll flag you as
being in the lowest 25%
and you'll be able to understand
that you should prioritize
fixing your app in that area.
So the first area is stability.
This is all about providing a
robust and stable experience
to your users that is reliable.
There are two performance
metrics within this area.
The first is your ANR rate,
or Application Not Responding
rate.
This is when your app freezes
for more than five seconds.
Second area is crash rate.
This is when your application
closes on the user.
The second performance
area is battery.
So this is where your app is
using the radios or the CPU
unnecessarily.
And the two performance metrics
that we're focused on here
are stuck wake
clocks, so this is
where you hold a wake
lock for more than an hour
when the device is
supposed to be idle.
And the second one is wake ups.
This is where you're waking up
the device more than 10 times
per hour when the
device is idle.
The third performance
area is rendering.
So this is providing users with
that silky smooth experience
on their device so that
they feel like your app is
responsive and fluid.
The two areas that we have in
this metric are slow rendering,
so this is when
50% of your frames
take more than 16 milliseconds
to be rendered so you're not
achieving that 60
frames per second
that users expect
from their device.
And the second one
is frozen frames.
This is where 0.1%
of your frames
take more than 700
milliseconds to be rendered.
This is where users can actually
really feel that there's
a lag in the application.
Both of these are shown in
the Play Developer Console
alongside all the other bad
behaviors that I mentioned.
So you can go to the
Play Developer Console
as of right now, and
you can be able to see
this data for your application.
And then you can be able to
focus on improving those core
metrics.
For each one we provide links
to developer.android.com,
which gives you
help articles of how
you can be able to fix
these issues yourself.
Finally, if you don't care
about your star rating, which
I'm sure most of
you do, we also have
other reasons why you should
care about this performance
area.
We're starting to
use this performance
data in the promotability
in the Store itself.
And other things
that we're going
to talk about later on today
at 5:30 in a talk on the top 10
things to improve the
stability of your application,
you can be able to
learn more about how
we're improving the Play
Store to be able to use
this performance data.
Now I've talked a lot about the
field data with Android vitals.
Now I'm going to welcome
Riccardo on stage who's
going to talk about how you
can be able to understand
the performance of
your application
before you launch it.
[APPLAUSE]
RICCARDO GOVONI: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
It's great to be here today.
Today, I want to talk
to you about the Play
pre-launch report.
The pre-launch report
summarizes issues
that are found when testing
your app against a wide range
of devices.
We launched it last year
in the Play Console,
and you can find it there today.
Pre-launch report
actively contributes
to the success of apps, and
already thousands of you
are already using it
to create better apps.
And I want to mention a few
updates that we have about it.
The key aspect of
pre-launch report
is app stability testing.
We use a robot crawler to
automatically test every APK
that you upload to
alpha or beta channels
in the Play Console against
several physical Android
devices.
The robot tells you if
it encounters any crash
during a five-minute crawl,
which means that you can then
fix the crash before it reaches
production and your users
will not leave a one star
review because of that.
In the past the year, pre-launch
report has seen great momentum.
Over 58% of Play top apps
have opted in into using it,
and we have conducted over
6.5 million robot crawls
across hundreds of
thousands of APKs.
But the number that I like best
is not this one, but this one.
In 85% of the cases when
pre-launch report found
a crash, the app
was not later pushed
to production, which means
that millions of users
have not experienced
crashes that
would have otherwise affected
them, which is pretty nice.
So we continually
improve pre-launch report
to make it even better.
For example, to allow the robot
to explore more of the app
with data that you
control, you can now
provide test credentials
that the robot
will use to pass
through login screens
and explore more of the app.
Pre-launch report
automatically scans your up
for vulnerabilities and privacy
leaks using the knowledge
of Google's own security teams.
Over the last year
we added new scans,
and now we detect over
30 different types
of vulnerabilities
and privacy issues--
from using obsolete
libraries that
have known issues to
linking identifiers.
Pre-launch report also
capture screenshots and videos
during the crawl.
We improved the way we captured
them and we collect them,
and we now take into account
the structure of your app--
such as the activities
that's composed
of and the transitions--
to better cluster the
screenshots intelligently.
And this gives you a
better view at a glance
of how your app looks like
across its various parts, which
is great for spotting visual
inconsistencies in your app
look and feel.
But this is the one
that I like the most.
We added new
devices to the farm,
including the Google Pixel
running on Android O Preview.
So that means that
without any work,
you can check how your
app performs on Android O
and be ready for when it
launches later this year.
So you can go and upload an APK
right now to the Play Console
in alpha in beta, and
there's a good chance
that by the end of
this talk you get
a sense of how your app
performs on Android O.
Or at worst, it
might take an hour.
So this is all I
have for you today.
I hope the pre-launch
report gives you
that sense of amazing
security that other developers
like Playdemic are
already finding on it.
And I would like now to
introduce on stage James
Smith, project manager on Play.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES SMITH: Thanks, Riccardo.
Hi, everyone.
As Android developers, one
of the most important things
you have to look after is your
app sign-in key because you're
app sign-in key ensures
the security and integrity
of your app.
Lost the compromised keys
can be a very serious issue.
Your private key is
required for signing
all versions of your app.
If you lose or
misplace your key,
you will not be able to
publish updates to your app.
Your only option would
be to publish a new app
under a new package
name and ask all
of your users to move across.
This would be obviously
a terrible experience.
So that's why we're very
excited to be launching
Google Play app signing.
If you join this
program, Google Play
will manage your
key on your behalf
and sign your app before
delivering it to users.
It's really easy to get started.
First, you securely upload your
app sign-in key to Google Play.
That means it is now
safe on Google servers
and you don't need to
worry about balancing
security and convenience
of access to your key.
You can even delete it.
Now, to make sure that
updates to your app
come from you, the
authorized developer,
any new APKs you upload will
be signed with an upload key
that Google uses to
verify your identity.
The upload key can be reset,
which avoids the key loss
scenario I described earlier.
We've had several
partners using Google
Play app signing for a
while, and the feedback
has been really positive.
Here, Robin Hood speaks
to the layer of safety
that we've added, while at the
same time all but eliminating
the worry of having
lost or stolen keys.
Now, once Google
Play signs your app,
we can go one step further,
and we can provide optimization
services at your request.
The first optimization
we've decided to focus on
is making apps smaller.
We know that developers
care about app size
because users do.
APK size is correlated
with download success
and with uninstall rate.
Looking at APKs, we can
see that developers include
native libraries and different
architectures and drawables
for different screen
densities so the apps look
and run their best
on every device.
But this means that a lot
of the contents of an APK
is unnecessary for every device.
If I have a phone with a 32-bit
architecture and a HDPI screen,
then I only need the
contents of the boxes
in blue in this diagram.
And the rest in
green is completely
unnecessary for my device.
With app optimizations,
Playable delivered
just the right content
for each device.
You give us a universal APK,
and we will automatically
create optimized APKs
for different devices.
We're just getting started
exploring this area,
and it's still early.
But we've tried
this out with apps
that were in our
Early Access program,
and we expect the average
signing to be about 15%.
However, some apps have
seen better results.
Deliveroo was 33% smaller
after optimizations.
And the 7 Minute Workout app was
nearly a half smaller, at 48%.
So when can you
get these benefits?
Well, app signing
is available today.
We are trialing app
optimization in beta
with a few partners
at the moment,
and we hope to widen the
beta in the near future.
If you are interested
in optimizations,
please enroll in
app signing today.
And if you'd like to find
out more about these topics,
please come to our talk at
2:30 this afternoon on stage 1.
Thanks.
I'd now like to invite Mike, the
engineering manager on Google
Play, to talk about
device catalog, which
is also available today.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE DAVIS: Thanks, James.
So as we saw at the
start of this talk,
the Android ecosystem is
seeing significant growth,
and this is in part
due to the diversity
of Android devices with a
range of different capabilities
and price points.
We hear that you love the
reach that this brings.
But understanding
this device space
and targeting the right
devices can sometimes
be a bit of a challenge.
And so to help
with this, we have
launched a new device catalog
section in the Google Play
Console.
Using everything that
we know about Android,
we've gone from this
long list of device codes
to a rich, full-featured
device catalog.
Looks pretty awesome, right?
So what can this do for you?
First of all, we provide
detailed device specs including
RAM, system on chip, GPUs,
screen size and OS version
for every one of the
thousands of Android devices
that are certified by Google.
We also group these
devices into models
and allow you to drill
down to understand
the variations between them.
To help navigate
this device space,
we provide search and filter
options, allowing you to slice
and dice the catalog by
various device features.
For example, you can
use this to quickly
find all SDK level 24 devices
with the Snapdragon 810 SoC.
Or, as you see here, all
devices manufactured by Google
with more than 2 gig of RAM.
And as you may
have noticed, this
is more than just device specs.
With any filter we also
provide key metrics
for how your app performs
on these devices--
such as installs, average
ratings, and revenue.
In addition to this, we've also
introduced another new feature
we call device exclusion rules.
This allows you to
exclude your app
from a specific targeted set
of devices using key device
performance indicators.
For example, if you're
developing a rich graphics
game, you could use this
to only target devices
with more than a gig of RAM.
You could also create
a rule to exclude
all devices with a
particular system on chip.
This can allow
you to temporarily
prevent deployment of
your app to a specific set
of problematic devices
until you can push a fix.
Whenever you create
an exclusion rule,
we will always show you which
devices will be excluded along
with installs and
any metrics to help
you make this important
decision with confidence.
As you can see,
Space Ape Games have
found a great way of
incorporating these new device
tools to reduce costs
and improve KPIs.
To hear more about
this new device catalog
feature along with other
release management tools,
you can check out the
recording of this talk that
was presented yesterday.
Also, please swing by the Play
Console Sandbox area in dome C,
where myself and other
engineers from the Console
are available to give demos,
answer questions, and hear
your feedback on this or
anything else relating
to the Google Play Console.
And with that, I'm going
to hand you over to Suzanne
to tell us about even more
new ways we have to help
you release with confidence.
[APPLAUSE]
SUZANNE VAN TIENEN: Thanks,
Mike, and hello all.
I will walk you through
the release dashboard
which we launched yesterday.
You want to make sure
that your production
release is successful.
We've always been ahead
of the curve with tools
to prepare greater releases.
Think about the
pre-launch reports
that Riccardo discussed
earlier and our alpha and beta
channels.
But now, we also
give you the data
to monitor your
production rollout,
out of the box without
a need for an SDK.
This data is offered
in low latency,
and it can help
you make decisions
about your rollout sooner
and with more confidence.
Let me show you
a few highlights.
When you push the new
release, you obviously
care about crashes.
We give you absolute
numbers as well as
crashes per 1,000 devices to
put those numbers in context.
The default view
shown here offers
a comparison between
your current release
and the aggregate
of all app versions
that you have in production.
If something does
look off, you can then
go straight to the
crash clusters page
to see if you introduced
any new crashes.
Releases aren't all
about crashes, though.
You also want to see
ratings and reviews that
are specific to
your latest version.
When the rating for
your latest version
is significantly lower than
that of your overall rating,
you may want to start looking
into your one and two star
reviews to see what's
going on, and possibly
even halt your release.
But what if you can
also see install events?
Broken down by new
installs and updates,
this can tell you whether
enough users update
to your new version to push your
rollout onto the next stage.
And think about the power of
knowing how many uninstalls
came from updated devices.
Are you losing
existing customers
because your latest version
isn't performing well?
Play has these numbers
for you out of the box.
So I encourage you
to think about what
makes a healthy release.
Your crash tool may warn you
if you have a huge spike.
Your PM may panic if
your ratings tank.
But what about subtle
but significant changes
across metrics?
Would you ever notice
if you didn't see them
all in one place?
And to empower your decision
making even further,
we also let you
compare your release
against a previous
release of your choice.
This gives you
even more context.
You don't only have
your crashes and ANRs.
the impact that these
are having on your ratings
and then your uninstalls.
But you can also see
how these metrics
compare to a previous release
that you considered successful.
All in one place, all within
hours of your really starting,
helping you minimize
the time a bad release
spent in production.
So next time you roll
a new version out,
monitor it with the
release dashboard.
It just the new top most item
on the release management.
And now over to Preston,
engineering manager,
to talk you through the
new statistics pages.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESTON JACKSON:
Thanks, Suzanne.
Hi, everyone.
We've been hard
at work this year
addressing your top
requests in Play statistics.
I think you'll be quite
pleased with what we
have to share with you today.
I'd like to introduce the
new Play statistics page.
From this snapshot,
you can start
to feel the magnitude
of effort we
put behind the stats experience
since last I/O. Right now,
I'll briefly touch on just a
few of my favorite features.
First, let's drill down
into date selection.
As you can see, we still
have the preset date ranges.
But these presets are not
sufficient for our app
and business needs.
So I'm happy to say that we've
added a custom date range
selector to let you choose
the period that you're
most interested in.
Next, we know that
many of you manually
compare data in the Console
with data from previous time
periods.
We've made that
process much simpler
by plotting a
comparison time period
right alongside your
selected date range.
This allows you to easily
see period over period trends
that will highlight the
impact of releases, marketing
campaigns, and even
public holidays.
But time periods aren't the
only thing we want to compare.
Now in the Play statistics page,
you can select multiple metrics
to compare at the same time.
When you can easily
compare related metrics,
such as crashes and ratings
or installs and revenue,
you can start to uncover
relationships in your data
that are specific to your
app and to your market.
The last thing I'd like
to mention is hourly data.
We're introducing
new stats to help
you understand the behavior of
your app throughout the day.
This knowledge will help you as
you plan time-sensitive events
such as releases.
But to me, the most exciting
part about hourly data
is that you won't have
to wait until tomorrow
to start to see data for today.
I think you'll agree
that we've made
Play statistics more useful to
help you build successful apps.
I've only touched on a few of
the things that we've added.
I'd invite you to come
and join us in the Sandbox
to talk about more.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Tamzin,
our business development lead,
to talk about User Acquisition.
[APPLAUSE]
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Thanks, Preston.
So once you're confident
that your app's health
and performance
is optimal, you'll
probably want to drive new
valuable uses to your app,
right?
Well, in my job, I talk
to developers every day.
And they tell me
how critical it is
to understand how effective
their marketing channels are
at acquiring and retaining
new and valuable users.
They tell me they need more
data to make the right decision
about where to spend
their money and where
to spend their time and effort
in optimizing their growth
strategies.
Since last I/O, we
launched two improvements
to the User Acquisition
report to make
this area of the Console
even more useful for you.
Now just to remind you,
the User Acquisition report
shows you how many users go
to your Store listing page.
Of those, how many
people install your app?
And of those, how many
people buy, and buy again?
So the first improvement
was that we added country
to the User Acquisition
traffic breakdown.
And this is really
critical because we
want you to expand and succeed
and reach those two billion
monthly active Android
devices around the world.
Now this report is great
because it will show you
where the unrealized opportunity
is so that you can prioritize
your international expansion.
The second improvement is
that we added peer benchmarks.
Now this lets you see how
your app conversion compares
to similar apps in
the same category who
monetize in the same way.
Now this is available both
in the Acquisition report
and in the country report.
So it lets you see obvious
areas for improvement.
It lets you see areas to further
invest through Acquisition
and lets you celebrate
your team's success.
Now I'm pretty confident
that most of you
here care about building
long-term customer
relationships, right?
So today I'm really
excited to announce
version 2 of the
Funnel, especially
for businesses like yours who
have a strong focus on user
retention.
It shows retention
periods, which
are a critical metric
for understanding
which channels are bringing
your most loyal users.
And this is your
retained installer base.
It shows you the opportunity
to increase retention
using notifications and email
or increasing your app quality.
So from today, you'll be able
to identify which channels
are bringing you your
most valuable users, which
countries they're
coming from, and you'll
be able to identify the
opportunities you have
to increase your install
and [INAUDIBLE] conversion
and increase your
use of retention.
Now all of these reports help
you optimize for your growth
strategies, not
just for installs
but for long-term
business success.
So regardless of the
way you monetize,
we have an acquisition
report that can
help you grow your business.
Now if you want to learn more
about this or the release
dashboard or the
new statistics page,
you should come to stage 1
at 1:30, right after this,
and watch "Making Data on
Google Play Work for You."
So come and see us.
Now to tell you more
about improvements
we've made to reviews,
I'd like to welcome back
on stage Fergus.
[APPLAUSE]
FERGUS HURLEY: Great.
So I'm back again to
help those people who
had their hand up
earlier about trying
to get a five star app on Play.
We've made radical improvements
to the whole ratings
and reviews section on the Play
console over the past year.
I'm going to tell you some of
those improvements we've made
and we've just announced.
So one thing we announced
at Google I/O last year
was reviews analysis.
This enables you to be able to
see the topics that people are
talking about in your
reviews on Google Play
and prioritize which
topics are having
the largest negative
and positive impact
on your rating in the store.
You've heard from
developers that they
are using this to be able
to prioritize their feature
development.
And we're now expanding
to other languages,
so you can be able to understand
what people in geographies
that you have your
app available but you
don't speak the language are
saying about your application.
So the second most popular
language on play is Spanish.
And as of yesterday, we
now have Spanish topics
available in reviews analysis.
And a major market for
developers on play in Japan.
So we also now support
Japanese topics.
This is where we are putting
Google's machine learning
to work for you to be able
to understand your users
and what they're saying.
A limitation on the
Google Play reviews
for developers over the
past couple of years
has been that, when users
update their reviews,
you were only able to see the
latest update of their review.
Now we're enabling it to be
able to see the full review
history of the reviews that
that user has left for your app
unless they completely
delete their review.
This enables you to be able
to have a fluid conversation
with your users and
be able to communicate
with them effectively.
So once you start
engaging with your users
and you start responding
to their reviews,
how do you understand if it's
actually working for you?
Well, we have updated
rating section.
This is where we show you
what is the change in rating
for reviews that you've
responded to versus ones
you haven't responded to.
And what we see
is that developers
are seeing major results
in improving the star
rating of their app by
engaging with their users
because users in general
update their rating
to a positive rating as a
result of engaging with them.
Finally, another
improvement we're
making to the reviews
area is the ability
to be able to flag
reviews that have passed
through our first
level of flagging
that we do internally
of reviews, where
if you think that one of
the reviews that is posted
on your app does not match
our posting guidelines
and has been filtered through,
then you can be able to flag it
and we'll do another
manual to review, check,
and evaluation of that review
to be able to determine if it
matches our posting guidelines.
And if it doesn't,
we'll remove that.
This has already been rolled
out to a percentage of Play
developers, and it
will be rolled out
to the rest of all developers
over the next couple of months.
If you learn more
about the secrets
to being able to get a
higher-rated app on Play
and increase your user
retention, come to the talk
we have later today at
5:30 we are to learn more
about the things I talked about
in Android vitals earlier,
the things Ricardo mentioned
in the pre-launch report,
and these ratings topics
that I just talked about.
I'd like to welcome Tom, who
is a product manager on Google
Play, to come on stage now
and talk about subscriptions.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM GRINSTED: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm super excited to be here.
So let's just
imagine for a second
that you guys have used
all the great tools
that you've heard
about over this I/O.
And you've worked
with your teams
and you've made awesome apps.
How do you monetize them?
Well, we think one
of the best ways
to do that is to use
subscriptions on Google Play.
And one of the reasons we think
that is because subscriptions
are growing stratospherically.
We heard from Purnima
earlier on that the number
of active subscribers on Play
has doubled in the last year
alone.
That's great, but
it's only one data
point for a long-term trend.
In fact, consumer spend
on subscriptions on Play
has gone up 10 times in
the last three years.
That's an amazing
opportunity for developers
like you to make more money,
more regularly, and more
reliably.
And I'm going to
go out on a limb
and say that that
probably sounds pretty
good to quite a lot of you.
And quite a lot of us at Google
have been trying to help you,
have been really
working to power
your subscription businesses
So today I'm going
to share a few
of the slew of new
features of subs
that we're launching
at I/O this year.
These are features
to help you guys.
Now we know that to run
a successful subscription
business, you need
really good data.
So I'm really happy to say
that earlier this week we
launched a brand new part of the
Play Console, the subscriptions
dashboard.
The subs dashboard
pulls together
key metrics and information
about your subs business
and puts it all in one place.
So at a glance, you can see your
total number of subscriptions,
your new activations
and your cancellations,
your daily and your
30-day rolling revenue,
and even your top
performing subs.
This is a great area to get
an overview of how well you're
doing.
It's brilliant if you want
to spot trends or identify
anomalies.
And when you do
identify an anomaly,
you're going to
want to know more.
You're going to want to
know even better data.
And for that, over
the coming weeks,
we're launching three brand
new click-through reports each
tailored to keep part of
your subscription lifecycle--
the acquisition report,
the retention report,
and the churn, the
cancellation report.
So let's look at them
all very quickly.
The acquisition report
builds on the wonder Funnels
that Tamzin showed earlier.
But now it's a Funnel
that's tailored especially
for your business.
So not only can you see
which of your channels
drive the largest
number of installs,
but you'll see which
drive the largest
number of free trialists,
and which of your acquisition
channels eventually
drive the largest
number of high-value,
repeat-paying subscribers.
If you care about putting
your money and your effort
into the channels that give
you the highest-value users
on subscriptions, this
is the report for you.
Secondly, there's
the retention report.
This powerful new
report allows you
to compare different cohorts
from different subscriptions.
So if you've got a brand new sub
that you're experimenting with
and you want to see if
outperforms your others,
you can quickly
and easily plot it
and make that
decision to make it
the primary one that you sell.
Or if you try to use some
of our advanced features
like introductory
pricing, for instance,
then you can see here the impact
it has on your [? burn down. ?]
This is a really,
really good place
to inform your product decisions
to increase your retention.
And lastly, there's
the churn report.
So let's be honest, when someone
cancels your subscription,
it sucks.
But this report rocks.
And the reason I
love this report
is because for the first
time on the Play Console
you can see the exact
days that people choose
to cancel your subscriptions.
This means that you
can start seeing
the impact of that
release that you
made to try to lower
your cancellation rate.
Or, you can use is to start
building the business model
behind that feature
that you think
is going to keep people
around for longer.
Taken together, these three
reports and the dashboard
give you a view
into your business
that you have never been able
to have on the Play Console
before.
But we know that the insights
you derive from these
are only the beginning
of the story.
Because those insights
drive your decisions,
and those decisions drive
what tools you choose to use.
So I'm also really happy
to say that this I/O we're
announcing a brand new
tool called account hold.
This will allow you to know when
a user's payment has failed,
which is one of the leading
causes of subscription
cancellations.
At that point,
account hold will let
you withdraw the entitlement of
your great content in your app
and tell the user why.
You can say, hey, there's been
a problem with your payments.
Go into Play and fix it.
And the user will have 30 days
to fix their payment failure.
We've been working
with trusted testers
and trying this
feature out, and we've
seen a 25% increase
in retention rates.
So account hold and the
new subscriptions dashboard
are just two of
the many features
that teams across
Google are creating
to help you guys build
successful businesses.
Now hopefully that's
whetted your appetite.
So if you want to
know more, I really
encourage you to come along
to stage 1 tomorrow at 10:30
to join me and a couple
of colleagues as we
really delve deeply into
how to make more money using
subscriptions on Google Play.
So with that, I'd
like to invite back
to the stage Purnima and Matt
to round this session out.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HENDERSON: Thanks, Tom.
So much new stuff.
So in addition to making
use of the sessions,
please do go online to
G.co/play/developers.
You can read much more about
all of this new stuff there.
And also think about who
else in your organization
can become a user
of the Play Console.
And also, if you
haven't already,
I do encourage you to
download the Playbook app.
We've released a new beta with
a whole lot of new content.
It's a great way
to stay informed
of all of our announcements, our
blogs, and other great content
to understand the features.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: All right.
So hopefully that has
whetted your appetite
to try to build
amazing apps and games.
And I hope to see you this
evening at the Google Play
Awards at 6:30, where
we are celebrating
all the wonderful work that
has happened over the last year
I want to thank
you for challenging
goes to continuously innovate,
for adopting the features
that we invest in, and creating
things that actually provide
superpowers to your users.
So thank you very
much for being here,
and hope to see you
the Google Play Awards.
[APPLAUSE]